みんなにいる?
ミッドタウンでいい?
モロポンゲンでいい?
みきどこに?
全然どこでもいいよ
みきさんの中に何があったかな
いろんなものがあるね
ああ
えーと
でも
みきさんとルースと両方が好きなものなんてないかもしれない
私はね
ちょっと
後でもう一回
会いますけど
ロポして
もう一回会います
ああそうだね
でも何回一緒に食べる?ご飯
私は大丈夫
え?どうして?
なんでかと言うと
急にね
仕事が
イメージをもっと深くなってたかな
ああ
今日は
何しよう
こんなにお天気よくなっちゃってごめんね
うん
やだなぁ
え?ほんと台風どうしたんだろう
でも
台風で大変だったところもあるのよね
鳥栃県とか
こんな風にもあったのかしら
いやでも昨日雨降ってたよね
やっぱり
うん
え?
そう
天田部長
牛は知ってる?
あれ?
大変な雨が降りましたね
そう
うちのも全然降らなかったね
雨
え?そう
うん
全然
だから
雨が降らなかったのに
悪いことしたのかなと思って
今日やめたなんて言ったら
こんなにいいお天気ね
うん
だからよかったら
明日でも明後日でも行ってもいいけど
パパも一緒でもいいけど
うん
明日もしね
群馬に行くなら
明日
明日何?
なんて言った
えっと
群馬県
群馬県?
うん
あの
え?もし行きたかったら
じゃあ、メンメン…えっと…何だったっけ?
えっと、美術館、パラ美術館。
あっ、あ、私、夢とくんでも忘れちゃったじゃない? 今日出しといたのに…
あはっ。
あ、そうい…あぁ、ダメだなよ。
今日、もう、きゃすごく慌ててたのよ。 急にウィキさん、おりから言ってきて。
あ、そうか、そうか。
もう、あの、ウィキにも何か書かなきゃ、 悪いなと思って。
またちょっと書いたの、行った?
ああ、うん、ごめん、見てない。 もう、ちょっと、ちょっと…
えっと…
あ、そうか、80秒ですかね。 結局の生活から…